chỉ còn hơn 2 tháng nữa thôi là sẽ đến tháng 7 2.026
là cái ngày mà Hà Nội sẽ cấm xe máy xăng
lưu thông trong khu vực vành đai một
Cầu Giấy này bưởi này
xã đàn này ô chợ dừa này đê la thành này hoàng cầu này
toàn những cái tuyến đường mà anh em đi học đi làm
đưa người yêu đi chơi lên phố
rất là nhiều đúng không
thì tin vui Cho những AI đang đi xe máy xăng
trong đấy có mình
là chúng ta sẽ chưa cần phải bán xe máy xăng
chưa cần là phải đổi xe điện ngay bây giờ
bởi vì tin chính thức ấy là Hà Nội sẽ không cấm ô tô
xe máy xăng trong toàn bộ khu vực vành đai một
từ tháng 7 2.026
sẽ không cấm toàn bộ
đây là cái thông tin chính thức được đăng tải
trên báo dân trí
cũng như là báo vnxpress có đưa tin hôm nay
đấy là sở xây dựng Cho biết việc cấm xe xăng từ 1/7 2.026
sẽ được thí điểm Theo vùng
có lộ trình có phạm VI và đối tượng phù hợp
chứ không triển khai đồng loạt ở trên khu vực vành đai một
vậy chính xác thì
đâu sẽ là khu vực mà xe máy xăng không được lưu thông
từ tháng 7 2.026
Theo kế hoạch
thì khu vực đầu tiên được lựa chọn sẽ là khu vực lõi
trung tâm của phường Hoàn Kiếm
cái nơi mà đã có cái nền tảng là hạn chế phương
tiện giao thông cá nhân
từ mô hình là phố đi bộ
và cái phạm VI thí điểm ban đầu nó sẽ tương đối là gọn thôi
và giai đoạn tiếp Theo thì Hà Nội sẽ dần mở rộng Ra
toàn bộ khu vực trung tâm của phường Hoàn Kiếm này
tiếp cận thêm những cái phường khác và dần dần mở rộng Ra
Theo lộ trình từ BA Cho đến năm năm nữa
là sẽ Ra hết vành đai một
sang vành đai 2 và vành đai BA
Theo như cái chỉ thị số 20 của thủ tướng
nói ngắn gọn thì đây sẽ là một cái
tin rất là vui Cho những em nào mà đang đi xe máy xăng
là chúng
ta chưa cần phải bán ngay xe xăng để mà chuyển qua xe điện
xe máy xăng vẫn di chuyển đi lại được
trong khu vực vành đai một
chỉ có cái khu vực lõi
trung tâm thí điểm là mình không vào được thôi
còn lại thì hiện tại vẫn là ô kê he he